[Musica]
[Applauso]
buongiorno come hai dormito
immagino che questa sia una situazione
familiare per tutti
eppure spesso sottovalutiamo
l'importanza della risposta
voi come dormita vediamo alzi la mano
chi questa mattina si è svegliato
riposato brush adesso vediamo una cosa
contraria
alzi la mano chi ha dormito male almeno
una volta nell'ultima settimana e
nell'ultimo mese va bene adesso l'ultimo
sforzo
alzi la mano chi nell'ultimo anno ha
cercato informazioni o consigli per
cercare di dormire meglio di meno di
meno di quelli che dormono male bravi a
che ha fatto la ricerca perché dormire è
fondamentale per il nostro benessere
psicofisico
eppure troppo spesso trascuriamo
l'importanza del sonno come strumento
naturale per migliorare la nostra salute
eppure il sonno è un comportamento come
correre e mangiare e possiamo farlo in
maniera corretta oppure in maniera
sbagliata può essere influenzato da
molti fattori
il sonno è un comportamento perché il
modo in cui noi interagiamo con
l'ambiente circostante è il modo in cui
ci siamo adattati all'alternanza tra
luce e buio è un comportamento attivo
perché a parte che andare a letto è già
un azione ma perché mentre noi dormiamo
il nostro cuore e il nostro cervello e
il nostro corpo continuano a lavorare
incessantemente per aggiustare
analizzare eri a lavorare tutte le
informazioni acquisite durante la
giornata e prepararci per il giorno che
verrà
e tutto questo senza alcuno sforzo
chissà invece quanti sforzi fate per
cercare di rimanere in forma
sicuramente avrete cercato l'esercizio
fisico all allenamento più adatti a voi
l'esercizio fisico occupa il 4 per cento
della nostra vita per rimanere in forma
avrete cercato sicuramente la super
dieta quella dimagrante rimodellante in
grado di scolpire il fisico senza
rinuncia l'alimentazione occupa
all'undici per cento della nostra vita
alimentazione sana ed esercizio fisico
sono importanti
lo sappiamo ma i pilastri della salute
sono tre e sono sicuro che vi siete
sempre dimenticati di quello più
importante il sonno occupa il 30 per
cento della nostra vita ed è
probabilmente il modo più piacevole e
meno faticosa per rimanere in forma che
dormire sia una cosa importante lo
sappiamo già tutti d'altronde basta una
notte di cattivo sonno perché il giorno
successivo già ci accorgiamo di avere un
po meno attenzione un po meno memoria e
per chi studia qualche difficoltà di
apprendimento in più basta una notte e
di cattivo sonno perché anche la nostra
alimentazione e il nostro metabolismo
cambino perché mentre noi dormiamo viene
prodotta l'ormone della sazietà
la leptina meno sonno meno leptina più
fame e la fame verso quei cibi calorici
quei cibi che vanno a rovinare la nostra
dieta
e se abbiamo una notte di sonno cattivo
lo sappiamo che anche il nostro umore
sarà cattiva
il giorno successivo saremo più
irritabili più ansiosi e avremo più
difficoltà a gestire lo stress e delle
relazioni lavorative e familiari ma se
le notti continuano cosa succede beh la
prima cosa la vediamo allo specchio
vediamo il nostro viso aumentano le
rughe aumentano le macchie le impurità
le occhiaie
ma se le notti continuano ancora
aumentano le assenze da scuola dal posto
di lavoro
gli aumentano gli errori lavorativi e
aumentano anche gli errori alla guida i
soggetti che abitualmente dormono meno
di 5 ore hanno un aumento del 300 per
cento del rischio di incidenti stradali
e se le notti ancora continuano aumenta
il rischio di sviluppare patologie
croniche molto gravi
il sonno di qualità è caratterizzata
essenzialmente da tre elementi il primo
è la durata dipende dall'età
andiamo dai 14 dalle 14 alle 17 ore nei
neonati alle 6 7 ore di un'anziana ma
dipende soprattutto dalle cento dal
tempo che ci concediamo per dormire il
secondo elemento è la profondità le fasi
di sonno profonde sono quelle che alla
mattina ci danno poi la sensazione di
aver veramente riposata si concentrano
nei primi due terzi della notte e sono
influenzate ovviamente da quello che
facciamo prima di andare a dormire e dal
tempo che ci concediamo l'ultimo
elemento è la continuità avere un sonno
frammentato con molti risvegli ci darà
una sensazione di un sonno
insoddisfacente anche se le ore
complessive sono adeguate capite quindi
che i fattori che influenzano il nostro
sonno sono molti e la maggior parte di
questi fattori dipendono da noi dal
nostro stile di vita dipende
dall'alimentazione da quello che
mangiamo dagli alcolici dal fumo da
quello che facciamo prima di andare a
letto dalle attività sportive o dalla
puntata della nostra serie preferita
dipendono da un altro fattore sempre su
cui noi possiamo intervenire e che è
fonte di litigio in molte famiglie che è
la tecnologia computer tablet e
smartphone emettono una luminescenza che
va a bloccare la secrezione della
melatonina l'ormone del sonno è un altro
fattore che fa parte della vita di tutti
è il lavoro
la dottoressa ci ricorda però che il
sonno a delle malattie specifiche che
sono frequenti sottovalutate e spesso
sconosciuta avere difficoltà ad
addormentarsi avere risvegli multipli
svegliarsi troppo presso la mattina
avere la sensazione di un sonno non
ristoratore sono i sintomi dell insonnia
l'insonnia è la malattia del sonno più
frequente è una malattia va
diagnosticata e trattata in italia il 40
per cento della popolazione ha almeno un
episodio di insonnia all'anno il 10 per
cento soffre di insonnia cronica
purtroppo il 76 per cento non fa nulla
per migliorare questa situazione
esiste un'altra malattia frequente è
sottovalutata
russare russare nel tempo si associa
alle apnee del sonno che sono
un'interruzione involontaria del respiro
mentre dormiamo e quindi chi ce l'ha non
si accorge questa interruzione del
respiro provoca ovviamente una riduzione
dell'ossigeno nel sangue che causa la
sofferenza di cuore cervello che negli
anni porta sviluppare malattie croniche
e gravi
però queste app ne portano anche a un
sintomo il giorno successivo perché
ovviamente ogni apnea crea una
interruzione del sonno una
frammentazione quindi un sonno
inadeguato e questo nel giorno
successivo si associa a sonnolenza e ha
un nome e da un aumento del 400 per
cento del rischio di incidenti stradali
ma le malattie del sonno sono molte e
anche particolari abbiamo i disturbi del
movimento nel sonno come gli scatti il
mioclono notturno o la sindrome delle
gambe senza riposo
abbiamo le parassoni e che sono attività
complesse assolutamente normali in
veglia ma che sono in abituali e
bizzarre nel sonno come insonni l'occhio
il sonnambulismo i risvegli
confessionali arrivando fino ad ad
attività violente abbiamo poi disturbi
del ritmo sonno veglia
cioè quei soggetti che si addormentano
troppo presto la sera oppure troppo
tardi nella notte è la sindrome del
turnista il disturbo causato dal lavoro
notturna per poi arrivare alle patologie
associato a un aumento della sonnolenza
diurna come la narcolessia e di persone
capite che quindi sono molti fattori che
altro nel nostro sonno e molti dipendono
da noi ma noi possiamo fare qualcosa
migliorare questa situazione la prima
cosa è rispettate il giorno e la notte
non lasciate le briciole al vostro sonno
concedetevi almeno otto ore di sonno per
i bambini anche di più state attenti a
quello che mangiate a quello che bevete
a quello che fate prima di andare a
dormire
andate a dormire in una stanza
confortevole non dormite sul divano
spegnete almeno due ore prima di dormire
tutta la tecnologia createvi una routine
che vi permetta di rilassarvi
prima di andare a letto per allontanare
le preoccupazioni e lo stress della
giornata
siate regolari nel ritmo sonno veglia
possibilmente anche il fine settimana e
la mattina quando vi svegliate ascoltate
il vostro corpo
e se ancora avete qualche dubbio sul
vostro sonno
provate a rispondere a questa domanda
hai un sonno disturbato il tuo sonno
disturba gli altri la sonnolenza o la
stanchezza disturbano la tua giornata
se la risposta se fai qualcosa prima che
il tuo disturbo diventi una malattia del
sonno perché alimentazione sana ed
esercizio fisico aiutano a vivere meglio
ma se dormi bene vivi in forma
[Applauso]